so my name is david barnard i work for
the council on this program i don't
actually work for the council i work for
an organization called groundwork east
where our federation organization uh
underground uk
basically in environmental social
charity
so
as you probably are all aware
because i think most of you by looking
at your badges i hope i'm getting right
here because my outside isn't that great
most of you work for councils okay um
you're probably very very aware of the
emergency declarations that councils
have made about their plans to reduce to
uh net zero by 2030 2035 2040 whatever
obviously for suffolk and the
surrounding other councils baber i think
is one of them uh mid-suffolk et cetera
uh west suffolk um that bake is
basically made in 2030. so they're
putting putting it out there getting
there on the on the road map first so
essentially in terms of that um that
action plan
um so in terms of
suffolk's climate emergency declaration
to this 2030 target to net zero
they've looked at the road map basically
how they're going to get there
and
this chart although it's not it's not
time scaled in the sense of how things
are going to happen it's just basically
the progression of things that need to
happen to get to net zero in that time
of 2030
so the main thing at the start is
essentially we're going to have a
carbonization of the grid which
obviously helps reduce all the emissions
from electricity use
then we've got
a number of different sectors that
they're looking at so what needs to be
happening in domestic sector the housing
market what needs to be happening in
transport what needs to be happening in
industrial and commercial and they've
essentially broken in down to a couple
of three areas energy efficiency as
you'll see is always the first thing
they're looking for it's not the biggest
thing but it's like
really we need to have energy efficiency
reduce reduce reduce and then there's
other things that we can take on top of
that
and fundamentally as you've probably
heard a lot today through the
presentations and and the other um
people who've got their stands and
everything about effectively
decarbonization decarbonization of heat
decarbonisation of electricity and using
appropriate technologies
the challenge really from from a council
perspective because
the
the plan for 2030 is the whole it's not
the just the council's emissions the
whole of suffolk
so their real real challenge is
two things i think
one
as it says on this particular chart
they've got a are going to have a
essentially a residual amount of uh
carbon coming out of things like um
agriculture which is incredibly hard to
decarbonize um but also
but i think the main thing that they're
going to actually find challenging is
getting people on board
because this isn't their plan it's
everybody's plan because it's
decarbonization of suffolk
so they've got to get everyone on board
and that's really the where the strategy
should be taking them
and that really fits in with everyone's
commitment we should all be working to
that in regard so the big questions are
that are obviously people coming at you
for today what does it mean what does
what does net zero mean what does
you know where do we start
how can is impossible
is this is this realistic well hopefully
today you've got inspired people are
saying yes it is
but it's not easy
it's definitely not going to be easy but
it is and it's about that engagement
and really about how
the plan fits with the they say the key
motivations i think we hear peter say
earlier about getting momentum getting
people on board
um
so in this presentation i've got a
couple of examples of some organizations
that have done things um
and then obviously we'll have some
questions
so one of the one of the organizations
that
has been very proactive um is a
i could have chosen probably loads but
this this particular company precision
marketing um
basically they do what they say on the
team they're a marketing organization
they print materials and things like
that
and so then carbon
reduction
is makes business sense i think we've
heard that a lot today you know it just
makes business sense about how they can
reduce their emissions and these are
some of the ways they've been doing it
and they've done a lot of work through
a particular program that i'll come on
to mention later on
but this is in relation to them being a
member of
the carbon charter i don't know if it's
an organization it's been mentioned a
couple of times today um
essentially the carbon charter um is
something that was set up by the council
and i'll come on to that in a moment and
so they are a gold
charter member so that indicates
uh that they have done a lot because
there's three standards gold silver
bronze again i'll come on to that in a
moment but they are a gold charter
member to show they are up there and
have been for a while being
on what they've been doing so i'm not
going to read through all the slides you
can see that as easily as i can
another organization completely
different sector uh warren services so
they actually
are almost like in consultancy type
service they work with businesses but
they actually deliver obviously in their
own right they do
some manufacturing and things like that
um
if i remember them correctly um i
haven't worked with them personally um
but i think that's their main main gist
of what they do but again another gold
charter member so they've been in this
for a long time in fact i think they
were on a presentation not that long ago
uh that the suffolk county council
rounded and did a webinar and i think
they were invited along and so you might
have seen there
um
one of them on there saying what they've
been doing apologies i don't really know
much about that business i say i'll pick
this i picked this presentation up at
the last second so someone's throwing it
at me so so i apologize for that um so
yeah carbon charter what's it about um
so effectively the carbon chart was set
up by a sub county council
um
over 10 years ago now i believe it was
and they have expanded it um so as part
of a program called the be angular
program which is going to be probably on
my next slide or two
they've expanded into norfolk and so
there's two charters essentially they've
got the suffolk charter and they've got
the norfolk charter but they're
essentially one of the same it's just
branded slightly different
the aims of the charter are very much
based on this principle of gold silver
or bronze so
bronze pretty much you're starting your
journey you may have not done anything
at all you may not have even heard of
carbon footprinting so you have no idea
whatsoever you're just starting out and
you can get some assistance to do that
so you've been doing it for a little
while you've got some idea you've got
some data you've been doing some things
and you can evidence it and that's
really what that's about and that's why
the silver they're trying to look for at
least a 10 reduction
in how much
energy carbon you've saved over the
assessment period which is generally one
to two years
and then gold is that you are very
proactive business you've been out there
and it's actually more not just about
the carbon footprinting not just about
business activities in terms of internal
processes but it's about actually
engagement external process how you work
with suppliers how you get them on board
and work with suppliers that you say to
them well what your green credentials
and so you're you're doing that
engagement with them on that sort of
high level it may even entail some
community involvement how much you're
doing in
the community so it might be you you do
litter picks or go plant trees and how
much you work with your staff etc so
it's that much broader view and
therefore you become an exampler type
organization because it's not just
always in internal focusing and so it's
quite a high standard quite a
challenging standard
essentially
it was designed for small and
medium-sized enterprises in recognition
that a lot of businesses
of that size would struggle to
necessarily meet the iso excuse me the
iso standards
or the british standards that are
available
both terms in terms of money cost how
much it cost to get into those schemes
and also time commitments so this was
really trying to give something that was
really powerful
but but not so
intensive
in terms of the amount of effort and
money that was required
the other things about the charter is
fundamentally the networking
organization set arrangement so that
it's really trying to encourage good
practice
so there's an opportunity if you join
the network they hold events to
try and do a bit of networking sharing
and best practice learning that sort of
thing across the piece and so it's
really that's the key thing about
getting this engagement as well getting
like-minded people like-minded
organizations to work together and have
a collaborative a view of things often
they're not collaborating on projects
but just saying this is how we've done
it how the lessons we learn good things
the bad things etc etc
so that's what the the main aims of the
charter
um also there's now recently as you
probably might be aware um
suffolk
council have made a procurement ask
so when they now ask for tenders to come
in for purchasing of equipment or
supplies or whatever they're buying into
the organization themselves they're now
saying well what green standards have
you got and as part of that recognition
they are now saying oh yes the charter
is a recognized award we will accept
that as part of our procurement ask
and the reason for that is that it's not
just something the council set up it's
not just a council scheme the charter
isn't just them coming up this uh
accreditation process but it's actually
gone through the environment agency as
well so they're one of the lead
organizations that have supported the
carbon charter right from its inception
back in the day and therefore it's sort
of externally accredited to to them and
therefore has that weight behind it of
the environment agency backing up as a a
viable and and good system for
environmental management accreditation
so in terms of the charter what is it
looking at
and i think i've just mentioned the
words it's looking at the whole of the
impacts of your business it's actually
looking at that not just the energy the
carbon footprint but the broader aspects
of your environmental impacts
i've probably said all that actually
that's my next slide
okay so it's about understanding what
the what the what the what your impacts
are and i say there's a lot of support
around that uh and so that's what the
council really trying to do they're
trying to encourage
organizations to get involved in the
charter and so there's a lot of good
information they do have this uh the
website
um carboncharter.org
and on there they've actually made quite
a lot of information freely available to
organizations to hook up with um so
there's some
template
information guides etc and fundamentally
if you are a charter member
you get
this consultancy
free consultancy service
i'll have a caveat free
because essentially it is free
to certain organizations and i'll come
on to that in a moment but some of it
now is also paid for so it's not always
free
but
generally has always in the past been
free until quite recently
so this is a scheme actually that i
particularly work on um
which is a service we deliver on behalf
of
the council uh southern county council
particularly old norfolk council on the
be angular programme
it's a business focus program
it's aimed at again small and
medium-sized enterprises
well no haven't it aimed small and
medium-sized enterprises subject to erdf
fund i think i'm because i'm waving that
about um subject to uh erdf funding
rules so there are some eligibility
criteria that come into play but
essentially it's a small and
medium-sized enterprises
in terms of what we do we're
an advisory service we can provide free
support advice to to organizations
but fundamentally we're trying to get um
get people to do things so we offer
grant funding support and grant funding
support can be up to forty percent of uh
project eligible project cost
um and we essentially do pretty much
anything that will reduce carbon
emissions uh in support of grant funding
so we can
you know typical examples would be
people want to change out their light
into led we can help support that people
want to change out their um
equipment maybe to be more efficient
energy efficient equipment
solar pv that sort of thing we can help
there is one one or two things that we
can't support um what we did
quite a few years ago was decide that we
were not going to support any fossil
fuel improvements
so we're trying to dig because of
decarbonisation but we're trying to move
people from fossil fuels onto electric
so we're going to the transition
from fossil fuel to electricity so that
we're not into upgrading
gas boilers if people want to change
their gas board for a more efficient
boiler they won't get our support
we also don't do
hybrid vehicles for that very same
reason because it's essentially a fossil
fuel engine with a battery so we don't
do fossil fuels so that there are a
couple of things that we don't do but
essentially
pretty much everything else if it's
going to save some carbon
businesses can come to us for potential
grant funding support if they are an
eligible organization
um
it does say on my slide there i notice
there that it says the enquiries up to
2021.
um the reason that i think is there is
fundamentally the project ends june next
year so the be angler project ends 30th
of june 2022
but that's essentially all the money's
got to have been given out to all the
applicants by then which means in
process terms
what the funders are now starting to
tell us is we need all applications to
essentially be approved by the end of
the year hence inquiries bonded for 2021
for things to be installed early part
next year to then be able to claim back
their monies
by june 30th next year so that's why i
think they're looking at that time scale
it doesn't mean they can't get things
next year but i think
just the way it works getting stuff
installed can take a bit of time and
getting all that in
but in terms of the process it's a bit
like a cashback scheme in terms of the
grant the way the grant works
so
you have to get approval first
we can't pay for anything
retrospectively you get approval from
the funders
you then as an organization would
install the measures that you've asked
the funding to be done as you would have
done anyway
so you go ahead and get quotes and all
that put that to us then you get the
works done and then you claim the
money's back at the end
if that makes sense so i'll recap that
because i don't know if i muddled that
up but basically you come to us with an
idea you say i want to do something
we assist you in getting the approval
you then get approval hopefully for the
amount of grant funding that you're able
to get you would then go and install it
as an organization and then when it's
installed and you can evidence that it's
been installed you make your claim back
so everything has to pay for upfront and
then you get your
your money's back at the end hence that
deadline of 30th of june 2022 when the
monies has to be paid out
oh that's it that's my last like so i
say that's um
the two main programs uh
that uh that i've mentioned the b angler
program and the carbon charter
in terms of
uh say the be anglia
we do
offer the carbon charter for free
which is why i say in some most cases it
is hopefully for free uh as part of the
service under the be angular program so
if you're an eligible organization under
b
you can get
the carbon charter initial accreditation
for free
but if you're not an eligible
organization then i say there may be a
cost
thank you very much
that was pretty a very quick gap through
um is there any well i think there are
questions
yes please do very good question yeah so
in terms of you mentioned the carbon
charger three the angular in terms of an
accreditation do you have to
have a grant three be angular
to then get carbon class and carbon
charge and accreditation paid for but
acquired angular
no
they're totally independent of each
other yes you can have a grant you can
have a charter or you can have them both
okay great thank you
what is the um the criteria for
analytical business ah
uh how long have we gone
okay so there's certain sectors that we
can't work with so fundamentally there's
some sort of golden rules as to
non-eligible sectors
so they would be things like we can't
work with steel industries we can't work
with synthetic industries we can't work
with big energy users
effectively so ship building those sort
of things we can't work with statutory
services so that's councils or things
like that health education those
services have been delivered effectively
on behalf of the government even if it's
in the private sector
so if you've got a private dentist
they still can't get funding or get
support through b angler because
essentially it's a statutory service
they're delivering on behalf of
so there so there are a number of rules
agriculture we can't support
primary production of food
marketing or delivery of so so there are
definitely some erdf no goes i'm afraid
charities
charity cios one uh sole traders yes
they're all coming under the sme banner
um
i think it said on one of the slides
maybe not can't remember but the
threshold on employees
um so you can't have more than 250
full-time equivalent employees so 249
249 employee full-time equivalence makes
you an sme
um
turnover and
balance sheet
are either or so you can have one of
them above or below but as long as one
is below these thresholds you're able to
uh to be possibly eligible so 43 million
euros
in terms of balance sheet per year or 50
million euros on your turnover so if
you're above those you're not an sme so
you therefore you wouldn't get support
3b
can i ask
if you've had applications from
land owners or farmers
no because we can't we can't do farming
um although we can support so can't do
agriculture okay um
because
that's
get support through other mechanisms
then they they can't get support through
us i mean certainly their financing has
changed this year
uh for farmers because we've come out of
the european union
without that support well that's a shame
actually what about um pops and things
like that yes pubs have done lots of
pubs
i'm a councillor so i'm interested in
what i can encourage my residents to do
yeah so if you if you i mean i say
pretty much everything i'm gonna say
there are some known goes i'm afraid and
then most of them are listed on our
website the angular website and it does
tell you there all right so i'll try to
give you an overview today but there is
some information on there uh and if you
need more information i'm happy to help
you but we have got some examples if you
are able to
spend some time i've got to stand in in
the main atria and and show you some of
the examples we have worked with and
certainly
public houses are places we have worked
with a lot yeah it's a shame about the
farmers actually
because
they've all been trying to diversify
because of the changes in the
their financial support from europe
and they're struggling actually
you know it just
seems to show that yeah so if it's a
diversified business let me get into
detail now
so this is a diversified business and
it's a
small or medium-sized enterprise in its
own right in other words it's got its
own autonomy so it's got its own
accounts its own legal arrangements
even though it might be uh a farming
structure you know that the the parent
might have been farming or it might be a
subsidiary of
if
they are sufficiently large enough in
their income to exceed what the farming
is making they might be eligible
it's a really weird rule um so you have
to we have to look at the economics of
it
but most farms are basically the primary
businesses the farming and they've got a
sub business and therefore that sub
business is much much much smaller yeah
then much much smaller therefore they're
swamped by their financial income
so really the the advice is for them to
if i was speaking with them say to go on
your website and that would explain
perhaps what they could
it will say agriculture primary
production is not supported
well in a rural community
i mean it's a bit difficult then isn't
it
i don't know i i think you provided the
clearly
if the hospitality diversification is
larger than the original farm then it
qualifies
and their energy supply has to come
directly into that part of the business
so if it's fed off the office if you've
got a caravan park on the side of your
house
then that's a domestic resident energy
so you can't we can't help them
because it's domestic energy
so i'd say that's why eligibility rules
uh uh
how the hell we got
it sounds straightforward at a high
level but actually when you're getting
fleet out again quite complex but the
point of it is
in in general terms
if you've got anybody that you want you
support for just come to us and we can
help because we will weed out and sort
out and try and work all this through
for them to say yes or no to them
so you're funded by the tile end of
european funding
um yeah and that's the reason you're
stopping in june
next year pretty much and so have you
had any um
guidance from the national government
that they're going to replace
can i can i can i take the sixth
amendment on that
whatever it is now i've heard nothing um
so as far as i know the program is due
but after them with government
commitments
that they will be making announcements
about ongoing funding but we've heard
nothing